mistake oh [ __ ] I'll just go live
so everybody and welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel and
I've gone live there by mistake so let's
just we'll just let's do the intro let's
do the intro let's roll it yeah
[Music]
why not always do the intro God damn it
so
we've got no stormy bear today he's got
to work
God building spaceships is a very time
consuming hobby apparently but we do
have young Matt
and that's tickling your ball dad then
because you leaned in just as I did that
because like
and
I can't way over there
Paris bear
good stormy bear and little Harris bear
I don't know why I've just just popped
into my head but
good evening wherever hell you are
how are you both young men
fantastic
I just wanted to check I am live we are
live excellent
I can't find the video on YouTube itself
though I might just be going crazy
well
let's have a quick look see because I'm
a little stressed that that's
something's gone wrong
yeah it's not in my subscriptions feed
live okay and now it's honest there it
is
an issue with YouTube there but now
we're on those are a little delay
we have a couple of people in the
comments Bob's with us Shelly's with us
hello everybody right so today we are
going to have a little bit of an open
chat we are here you are there we are
here and we're gonna have a little bit
of an open chat we can talk Stargate
I've got a few little questions to throw
you guys in the in the thing in case we
run out of stuff to talk about
um but also guys if you are watching all
hail
got the best name judican
Judah
um
if you want to throw any questions in
um on the side chat there guys that you
want to talk about please do and we will
chat about it if we know the answer so
between us one of us as well I am
flipping freezing
baby hello sir
um right so what's he got
give me one sec
that disappears just remember that's not
your trick you normally wait for me to
start the intro then you just come on
it will he be back in time we just don't
know do not leave me on my own right so
I thought yeah
while Matt's gone um as soon as the map
comes back everyone just put in the
comments
um I don't know something cheeky about
that let's think quick and everyone just
puts Europe I can still hear you
so I thought we would start by having a
little bit of chat because obviously the
big news this week Stargate related is
that Brad Wright is actually like
confirmed
um it sort of it sort of hinted a couple
of times before but he has really
confirmed he does not have any news
about Stargate because he is not in the
conversation and he he will not be
involved in any new Stargate series when
it comes there's been no conversations
with Amazon
um he actually said I'm not the place to
ask for news
it's very simply so I think we'll have a
little start that I did a little video
we chatted about it on the video got
loads loads of comments a couple of
comments I wanted to ask you guys about
but I I just love to know what's your
what's your first thinking on that was
that Amazon for one I was gonna say big
Studio seem to do this all the time they
don't even seem to speak to the people
that used to run the show like with um
Star Trek and that came back they didn't
even speak to Rick boom and all these
people they just went in completely New
Direction it's something Studio seem to
do for me I think it's a complete lack
of respect but but what do you guys
think about that news and that no Brad
for any new start
I'm not surprised like we've known about
it for a long time we've we've been in
the mindset that Brad isn't going to be
uh in charge of Stargate so it's been
what six six months or so since we've
first started hearing rumors of it of it
happening so I'm surprised
yeah I'm not surprised um
I don't know I'm kind of just used to it
I'm sad just because you know I just
told you I got to the first episode of
Stargate Atlantis I'm I am like halfway
through all of Stargate now and and it's
it's Brad's Stargate but
I I I will see that someone else will
probably end up taking up the Rings and
hopefully do well with it fingers
crossed
the one thing is and it's I was talking
to somebody else about this the other
day and it suddenly dawned on me
um you know they said they're looking
for a showrunner
um it was actually something the guy
that I talked to said and I didn't twig
when he said it
Amazon don't actually make an MGM they
don't have a studio they don't make
their own stuff
so it's going to be a little bit like
Star Trek that actually Alex kurtzman is
involved in that because he got he
basically works for the production
company that makes Star Trek because CBS
and Paramount don't actually make it
directly so they're talking about
stacking in what they're actually
talking about is getting rid of that
production company and going so in a New
Direction
so they're talking about for Stargate
looking for a new show and what they're
really looking for is a production
company to make the show
and that'll be exactly but actually I
really stupidly went back and had a look
at my emails off the chat that I speak
to and he basically told me that and I
just didn't I just didn't put two and
two together at all but that's basically
what he was telling me and I was just
like it does make a lot of sense
I'm really looking forward so what's
really going to get hopefully announced
either before or after Christmas is that
there's a there'll be in partnership
with the production but I'm actually in
production companies made sg1 was gecko
initially which is a Richard Dean
Anderson uh Anderson and somebody
company oh God I've seen that so many
times at the end of the episode but um
uh
and then I mean and then actually
um malozi and Brad Wright had a
production company for Atlantis nsgu
um
and they set up the production in Canada
they coped
um it's a shame really Brad I didn't
keep hold of some of the rights so that
they they have no choice but go to Brad
but but at one point is a production
company to run the show isn't isn't a
shock we just
they need one basically yeah so
um
maybe we've seen go-karting like they
did for Teen Titans oh God please kill
me Teen Titans goes in terms of
production companies for sg1 there was
double secret Productions Gekko film
corpse Productions which I'm guessing it
would be the um Brad right one
uh and karu's Productions
VII I don't understand Roman numerals so
if someone knows what that means seven
is it seven what what is
um
nine
nine so yeah anything in schools
nowadays they don't teach you Roman
numerals come on
okay
live on TV live on YouTube sorry
the only Roman numeral I know is x i
which is 11. I only know it because of
Red Dwarf the episode where like they're
they're in this um dream state thing and
for some reason the cat is intelligent
and you get and he sees e11t and he goes
oh e11t 11 is x i and Roman numerals
that means exit and then they get out of
the simulation that's the only reason
oh my God's sake right I I learned many
things from Red Dwarf too I learned how
to swear in front of my children without
actually swearing uh Snakehead smoke
trying to break his program is the
greatest thing ever
it's Warfare
I have not uh go back and watch the
original
what would you say map five seasons
Five series
well there was ten there was ten yeah
before they rebooted but yeah I said
probably say five is probably the
probably what's the first five or six
seasons then it starts going downhill
after that but so it was classic because
I mean it's the only ever real well
until Modern Times Really I suppose it's
um a live action version sort of lower
decks isn't it but it's it's a comedy
sci-fi which is such a rare thing and I
think Red Dwarf is really the first and
um it's obviously British and you've got
to get used to the you know [ __ ]
accents and things
the main character is a scouser so the
uh the accents are uh are up there yeah
as soon as just a hint as soon as rumor
leaves stop watching but anyway Stargate
people Stargate let's focus
um so one of the things I actually got a
lot of comments from people on the video
saying that Brad Wright definitely not
he's not involved it's not happening and
like I've been telling you for a year
even though people have been I've got so
much hate for that but anyway
um
it's
that a lot of people said well I'm not
if I'm not watching them
if Brad rice not involved forget it I
ain't interested
what do you guys think about that
I used to be I used to think that I I
when the conversation first started and
it was all Brad white might not be
involved I was like oh I'm not going to
watch it then but
I've had a long time to think about it
because we've known about this for a
really long time I just want to see
Stargate again I will watch it I'll give
it a chance
um
ah there's always the possibility that
whoever comes in is just gonna royally
mess it up yeah but I'm I want to be
optimistic I don't want to kind of be
that guy who just thinks it's going to
be crap because the mate because the old
show one is not I want to be a little
bit more positive about it
yeah right optimistic why not you idiot
it's gonna be rubbish
[Laughter]
everyone in the comments just gonna go
shut up Matt you don't know what you're
doing
how about you Eric
well I mean this is the first time I've
ever watched Stargate all the way
through and all that so
it's a it's a little
I guess I mean interesting for me
because you know I I'd love to see it
all because I'm getting used to it still
but
um
if they need new DNA I guess Amazon
thinks they need new DNA I don't think
that's the hills to die on I think the
hill to die on is that no hard reboot
but I I would rather that be the focal
point than I guess who's gonna lead what
because if there is enough material
where someone truly loves Stargate and
has watched it a few times that they
could take up the reins and do well with
it but
as long as we know as fans that they're
a fan as well I think we could be in a
good
lineup hopefully
I agree as long as they're fans and they
know the property
it's in good hands in my in my in my
eyes
yeah you'd hope so here has just said
what could they bring back Pride back in
to help I think that would be dependent
on which it's not just which show or
anything I've watched production company
produces the show do you know what I'm
fearful of it's something like bad
robots or something like that
trying to do it
it's the sort of thing they've tried to
do before
I mean it is kind of right up their
alley but I really hope not I don't know
yeah that would be a
H
that might be the one thing that would
make me go well this [ __ ] man I'm not
watching
yeah
um Amazon No Bad Robot please yeah
um I think that's the thing whoever
makes it we've got to watch it without
any preach which we've got to what did
we say over and over and over again when
we were talking about Lord of the Rings
and we said all these people coming up
going [ __ ] I'm not watching it's going
to be work six months before it was
released so we we mustn't go down that
road
yeah that's the way I'm thinking like
yeah
don't go into it thinking it's going to
be crap because if you go into it
thinking it's going to be crap then it's
going to be crap for you to watch if you
go in with a negative mindset you're not
going to enjoy it just go in thinking
it's going to be it's Stargate that's
what you've got to remember we've got
new stuff well we haven't but at the
time we've got new Stargate and it's
going to be amazing just [ __ ] watch
open mind Clean Slate open mind yeah
if you're going to look into hate it
you'll find it
true
um but if Bad Robot does it we'll be
blinded by the lens flares off the gate
opening and we won't be able to see half
the show and everyone know what's going
on but we're like we'll be like I can't
see from lens flares
do the car makes a good point I I made
the point in the video and I was talking
about this I basically said
they're missing they're missing an easy
tricky bring Brad on as something but
they should be talking to him now about
it bring him on as a consultant bring
him on his anything just to make the
fans happy they're missing a really easy
trick
just or otherwise the alternative is the
fans are going to go into it going I'm
not sure about this and they might they
need to be won over don't they the show
needs to be good enough to win them over
if they just bring Brad on we'll just be
excited we'll just be like waiting for
the first episode just like come on no
without Brad everyone's going to be like
this is going to be what crap it's going
to be rubbish and I don't want to watch
it instead of
what are you guessing
between him tapping or or Richard
Anderson himself I think those are our
Best Bets to actually be excited for a
new series I mean I know you've briefly
talked about both of them but Brad
Wright's kind of the guy but either one
of them would do well
and still excite us
what's the likelihood you know it's I
don't know if that likelihood's all that
high
was involved in some way
um has some sort of Cameo even just for
the first episode I can't just to tie in
this is this is a continuation this is
you know the same Stargate he's just a
dull man now
well it could be a retired General
giving advice to over the new leader of
the SGC is um I go to Great rumor a few
months ago that um when MGM still had
control of this and they thought they
were going to get Brad rights they they
thought they were going to as soon as
the sale went through I love how you're
trying to do that off-screen map no we
all know what you're doing
um I get told that's not the wires
when um I forgot my train of thought now
you distracted me with that idiot excuse
me oh sorry
um when MGM still had control of this
and they thought as soon as the sale
goes through they're going to be able to
green light and they were away they'd
done all the preliminary artwork that
apparently they've done storyboarding
preliminary storyboarding to like show
Executives they were they were doing it
um there was actually rumors that
Richard Dean Anderson was seeing in
things and he was losing quite a lot of
weight
um about 18 months ago it got quite big
and the Rumor was he was losing weight
because he was going to be in the new
Star game
um
whether that's bullcrap or not I don't
know
um but um Bob you always come up with
the best little random comments
bringing Tom Cruise's Stargate Top Gun
Tom Cruise everything fighter pilot
movie but Stargate it'd be great
um right hello there I was wondering
Amazon considered a Revival of sgu's
movies like its plans to show canceled
or a complete new start with at least 10
plus episodes right so the rumor that
I've heard
is that ideally
um Stargate want to come back with a uh
what Amazon's always plan a was always
movie followed by franchise
um no idea what the movie would be but
the movie was to set the new universe so
we all know where we're at and to kick
off into a new franchise
um but they always had contingency plans
um because of time and they wanted this
to be quite quick but then everything
has just gone absolutely I actually I'm
starting to think more and more it is
actually financial reasons why this this
hasn't happened as quickly as I thought
and we're going into an economic
downturn and I actually think Lord of
the Rings is a big reason why this has
been delayed quite a lot but I think the
biggest reason is the two people in
charge of MGM movies walked out or were
basically sacked
um I I actually think they walked out I
think they've been lied to so much by
Amazon and when they found out the truth
they just went I screw them and they
went to Warner Brothers
and MGM still haven't replaced them
so that's so it's a trifactor of
problems I think that's slowing it all
down
um
but ideally I think movie first but
would that be an SGU movie guys
I think it'd more likely be
the movie that never got made uh starget
Revolution not Extinction that was a
Stargate Atlantis movie but Revolution
was going to be the movie that
um disclose the target project to the
world
yeah if that's the direction they want
to go down
um that would I I
bet money on it that would be the movie
that they do
or at least a very very Loosely based on
yeah and I know Harris you haven't seen
SGU but do you know the rough promise
you know what you know why people are so
desperate for a conclusion to it is just
stranded out in space still correct yeah
they're just they're still floating out
there so there's been never there was
never any end to it so I mean
the comic book is Canon that finished it
correctly like uh
really
um
for me I don't think we're going to get
an SGU movie I don't think the franchise
by that point was popular enough I think
they're going to have a complete restart
I hope and Brad Wright was talking about
um when he hopefully was still going to
get it that he was going to do a
conclusion of SGU but I always thought
it would be like a double episode within
the series
yeah so you know I got 10 or 12 episodes
double episode within the series
they go save Eli I I think that's the
only way we're going to get a conclusion
we're going to see SGU again
but then I would love to see Eli don't
like his politics but David blue is a
really likable actor I'd love to see Eli
and and come into the SGC we in our
little fan fiction thing we've got him
coming into the SGC so I mean I think
that'd be really cool
um
but but yeah so that was I think right
repeatedly for 12 months sorry Matt and
repeatedly for the last 12 months um she
said I didn't say shut up Matt I'm
growing as a person
um is that Amanda Tapping they would
love Amanda Tapping to come back
um either as an executive producer or
even potentially as a showrunner but I
think it would be more likely to be an
executive producer with this role of the
they've got to find a production company
um so that's a thing but I've heard that
rumor three or four times
um what did you guys think I mean I I
think that's an easy way to make fans
very happy
yeah I love to if her name was attached
to the project
she is
well out of the original team you've got
Richard Anderson Miranda's happening
Christopher George and Michael Shanks if
it was
if it was her
out of all of them
that would excite people like
tremendously because if if if if it was
Michael Shanks or Chris Chris judge
you'd be like well what have they done
but people know about Amanda Tapping
and
if it was Richard Johnson yeah people
would get excited but again they'd be
like well what has he done you know
in that role but people know about
Amanda's having because she's done some
pretty cool stuff yeah exactly so if
that looks like me and that looks like
everyone as far as I'm concerned
yeah
yeah now what if it's both of them
that could be fun
well I mean Richard in Anderson has got
history on this gecko was his
partnership production company he
managed it
easy at an age where he would want to do
that and maybe just come in as
part of the management team basically
um but Amanda has got the behind the
camera skills to do this it would be the
next step in her career because a lot of
people said well she's never show her
and she can't do it she's done
everything but
you know it's it is the next logical
step
you know she
was executive producer on uh what what
news it was not I forgot the name of her
her show that she's ending right now or
finished up recently
um and she's just finished up Fort Salem
um but she is down to appear in an
executive produce another show called um
season zero something and yeah
the rumors I've heard is that that's
only got at the moment got a pilot
um I see the one room was but this was
just this guy's opinion so it was not
invested on any particular speculation
but he was saying I'm wondering if
they're waiting for that to do because
she signed up for contract to do the
pilot but nothing else so as soon as the
Pilot's done whether it's picked up or
not a man that can leave and come over
to Stargate
but they need to wait for that
process to go through until so you can
come across
um but that was just his for his opinion
it was like
um but that that would make sense to me
um I'd be shocked if Amanda Tappan
didn't come across in some respect
yeah I'd imagine she'd do some sort of
in the very least write an episode or
two
yeah yeah or direct coming in direct
episodes but I could see you sir you
know a Hands-On producer role for me
would be amazing I think I'd be great
uh
right I feel about
this is an interesting question because
shows take a lot longer to make than
they used to
so I mean 2023 or 2024 guys
um
Harris this is probably one for you to
be fair because I mean you you you know
this stuff I think are you seem to
producing a TV show nowadays
if they announced it January February
2023 could that be on our screens next
year
nope nope not at all uh I would I would
I wish I would love it to be but unless
they already had filmed at least the
pilot by that time
no
uh
if they have filmed the pilot they could
rush it and possibly it would have to be
a low budget Sci-Fi TV that they just
kind of tossed out there compared to I
guess taking a little more time I I
don't think that'd be a good idea for
them one way or another take your time
and you know make it what we all wanted
to be and expect it to be versus just
it's
flinging spaghetti at the wall you know
so if there is an announcement in
January February time unless they've
done a hell of a lot of leg work and in
the last six months that we don't know
about no chance yeah they can't do a lot
of the light work but then Amazon came
in and just
smashed it
that's what I started to do they were
basically told by Amazon we want
Stargate we want it fast and we want
this to be a big announcement you know
we want to really excite the fans about
this deal so MGM did all that work and
then Amazon actually took over and went
yeah I've changed my mind
they were scumbag Amazon they just took
what they'd done sacked them all and
were like well we're gonna run with this
and they've been they've been doing it
in the background we'd have no idea and
amazing
a little spin ball on this though JMS
when he was talking about Babylon five
he basically said back at the start of
the year and they were about to do the
pilot and he was hoping to get the pilot
filmed in like March he was hoping if
that got green lit and accepted and
everything he was hoping to have it on
our screens by four and they were going
to do 22 Episodes
and that's what they used to do they
used to do 22 Episodes a year every year
that's still CW and I don't I mean I
actually I will poo poo on the CW we
know what CW quality is like nowadays
that that's that's why that would be
like that we would not want that as as
Stargate people that would as the 22
episode sounds great but take take your
time on 10 or 12 and and give us
something that's meaningful versus
spaghetti tossed at a wall and seeing
what sticks yeah 100 I think
traditionally a TV show takes six months
um from Green Light to screen minimum
but that tends to be the more CGI you
have the more sets you have to build the
more whatever else it just extends that
and extends that but I mean if you look
at some of the big budget streaming TV
shows we've got now we're not looking
again after the dragon back until
possibly 2024
um Lord of the Rings won't be till 2024
I know that's not
that's completely different that's just
like
[Music]
um but some TV shows I mean look at um
uh the Netflix TV show the names just
come out and had stranger things yeah
yeah it's taken years I mean that's not
just filming though that's like getting
the actors there or what have you but
that's been a massive problem but I
would say it's possible 2023
but if they announced this in February
and it's going to be in the fall 2023
I'd be a little bit nervous about the
quality
myself yes they're not doing a
high-class unless they're not doing big
sci-fi it's going to be more people
based then they can do it if the CGI is
limited but
do we want that I mean you you did bring
up a good point in the way
Amazon's tackling Lord of the Rings and
even House of the house has the dragon
slightly different because you know Game
of Thrones was good about being every
year even with it being such an
expensive and hard to make show but they
knew they were going to get another
season no one knew if they were going to
like House of the dragon or not everyone
didn't like the end of Game of Thrones
so that was kind of hesitant there so
they they get a little bit of a pass but
Lord of the Rings they already they know
they're going to get a second season
with the type of money they spend on it
they should have already been in
production for a second season I feel
like if Stargate were to do that we know
there's going to be plenty of eyes on
that first season go ahead and green
light that second season and start
working on it and hopefully that would
kind of change their tune where they
don't want to rush it either and that's
like all right well we're doing two at a
time let's tell a long story and let's
see what I did with sg1 to be honest
they screen lit too serious straight
away it makes sense they did Children of
the Gods the studio loved it they
greenlit two seasons and I think you can
tell like because then there's the
confidence there to to tell a story and
like you said not rush it as a perfect
way
um talking about not rushing it then I
think
um Gene the actor well that's a pretty
name it's actually your name that's
lovely anyway
um
makes a good point here that there's
lots of ways you can slow burn a lot of
the reveal stuff in a movie I wonder
actually whether they won't reveal a
great deal I think if they do a movie
it's going to be 90 minutes two hours
there'll be a specific story and I'm
hoping we then come away with lots of
questions that they then answer in the
series
yeah do you think they need to do the
big reveal straight away or can they
save a lot for the series and then give
it to us in in bits and bobs I think
they could have
just a story in mind
um
just a mission that they're going on or
something which
has a lot of
hints towards other things that are
going on
yeah that could then be explored in a in
a in a television series yeah like they
mean it doesn't even have to be part of
the main story but they'll just talk
about like throwaway comments or
stuff that you'll see on screen that
fans will recognize and be like oh
that's maybe a link to you know the
season four of sg1 or Atlantis or
something like that and then it just
gets people a little bit more excited
and then they can explore it fully in a
TV show
yeah I don't think it's necessary per se
but it would be fun and if if they did
that and then even added the Stargate
revolutions type of ID on top of that
that'd be pretty badass because you
could do a team going through missions
and then having to come back through
Earth and while Earth is still I guess
the on Earth part to the the movie would
be
telling the public and then the team
coming back to a whole new kind of world
like oh [ __ ] they they let out the news
while we were gone
my wife's crying yeah like I would do
like a Star Wars stop and then just like
a long list of in yeah in 2015 the
Stargate was released to the public and
then the things
oh that used to be like [ __ ] me okay my
notes that's amazing what to do they did
but they've got to do that in the movie
they've got to excite a slot and that's
what they've got they've got to make a
good film
um you know they've got to do something
that's going to be action-packed and
interesting and exciting and get us
excited for the TV series that'll then
hopefully follow but they've also got to
excite the Gators we've we've got so
many questions about what's gone on in
12 years we need those to be answered
don't we
you know it's like I think so
because I just got to Brigadier Jack uh
and Jack O'Neill not no longer
Lieutenant Colonel Jack O'Neill so
there's got to be some brigadiering time
you know
that's a really good point like B5 of
the Shadows in the background to start
with and having something to build up
with I would absolutely love guys can
you just talk two minutes on yourselves
yeah the joy of filming from home
um I've got to talk about
um what sort of style of TV show do you
want to see when it does come back do
you want to see sg1 a monster a week
sort of episode
um thing like that or do you want to see
um
a
um sort of like an SGU SGA where it's
like based on the thing there's a
problem and that's sort of series what
what do you think should start and I
will be back in one minute
I I would like a hybrid I don't think it
should be monster of the week or just
one continuous story I think they should
be both they have like episodes you can
watch on their own and understand
but there is a a long game story that's
going to pay off like
at the end of the season or something
like an overall Arc
rather than yeah yeah rather than like
just oh we're gonna kill this go out
today and then the next episode doesn't
have any connection to it I think it
should be they're all connected but you
can watch them you can watch them
individually and still enjoy it kind of
thing okay so
I just thought of it maybe what about an
end or a style show and not not indoor
style and like the actual styling of the
show or anything but in the sense of
they have three or four episodes at a
time to complete a full Arc and then
three or four episodes to complete
another Arc and so on and so forth yeah
you were in the middle for a second
yeah
but you can do this
oh oh Jesus no no put me back over there
actually I've not watched yet I've not
watched and all yet so I can't I don't I
don't know what kind of style that is
but
yeah okay so essentially for the a lot
of people were saying oh it's it's it's
slow when it started and it was kind of
slow because the first two episodes were
the first and second act of a story and
then that third episode was like all
right let's let's give you a little
action and a student not super
action-packed but from there each three
episodes has kind of been its own story
working up to 12 episodes and that that
may be mixed in with that hybridization
style you were talking like give us
those arcs and then maybe give us like
an individual episode or two where you
can have like
six or nine episodes within like the
three structure Arc and then uh
one one or two you know
individual episodes to kind of just link
Seasons together or link whatever in the
past to the Future present whatever it
may be
I'll just answer this because he's been
kind enough to
um let's say donate
but first two percent so we used to read
super chats out uh how many stores do I
have right so oh God I should have
thought about this answer while we were
just talking
um give yourself away I know I've got
three really really good sources
um one in particular that works where
because where he works I get really
really good like um
um how the industry actually works
knowledge and um and another guy so so
two guys really one that's because he
does a lot of like contract work and
stuff and he was the first person to
ever come to me with sort of like this
information because he actually worked
he used to work for MGM in like
basically
uh he doesn't work there anymore so I
think I can say
um it didn't work for their company he
worked for a company that did all the
legal work for MGM
um but since Amazon came in they no
longer work use that company and he now
works actually for an agency doing
something a little bit different but
he's actually even better really I have
a couple of sources that actually work
physically in the MGM building
which is very useful
um they're not high up Executives
they're very mundane jobs but that's
nice but I've met all these people
through this original Source basically
and but I'd say I think I've got about
10 or 12 people that give me little bits
of information here and there now
um but there's three or four that
actually give me really good
regular information
um two in particular that are really
really good sources
um one of them got sacked you know I
don't know if you remember but remember
I did quite a
expressed video because they were
literally all difficult Amazon came in
and they went anywhere on a short term
contract they just got rid of them yeah
they were keeping their jobs or not
yeah so the one guy came out and went oh
basically I've been I've been sacked and
he was he worked in the he was a
creative he actually does
um CGI and he does that sort of thing he
works in the creative side of things on
that and he just got he just got his
contract just done so he just literally
walked out and he was actually escorted
out by security guard and I was actually
quite upset when I did the video and
because I was just like these are people
to talk to regularly you know he now
works for Warner Brothers I've got so
much good stuff for everyone Warner
Brothers
um nobody really cares but I got the
really good stuff I wanted
um I'm gonna do a video next week
actually I've sort of got an idea what
Warner Brothers doing over the next 10
years
and because he's been able to sort of
give me little little nuggets so um
huh what'd you say what sir what is it
selling the peacock Universal on like
four
yeah yeah
exactly yeah maybe uh no I would agree
with Batman is just
nuts
um
apparently well we're gonna have about
three different Batmans going at once
it's just whoops yeah that's what I did
different for different Universe Batman
universes we're gonna have the Batman
Universe which is not going to be
connected to the universe that Superman
is going to be coming into a Black Adam
and all that but then we're gonna have a
Batman in that universe as well and it
might even be Ben Affleck coming back
apparently there's been a conversation
and they would look for him to come back
um and uh there's going to be a well we
also got the animated that's the
animated is going to be having a big
comeback shortly
um and they might even be a third Batman
Michael Keaton right
well we've got that anyway but no a
different thing in the video I don't
want to spoil it because I don't yeah
give it to us in a week
it could be the future Batman I can't
think of his name all right screw it
again now they were going to do a Batman
Beyond series
uh live action
um
so we will have three and on HBO Max
apparently and it's going to be an adult
grown-up it's the the way it was
described to me was is like um a manga
cartoon live action
so I mean I'm imagining like 300 and
blood is flying everywhere and
everything
um and um or like uh Blade Runner but
with Batman or something like that
that's that's what
we'll see I've just completely ruined a
video thank you very much
video
yeah I can do that um
Batman in the next few years but
apparently that's the plan uh what about
sending me series to join back all the
common Point like SGC or something like
that actors brought in for short
commitments now I I think that's what
they're going to do personally you know
what I'm doing with our little SGC
series with our little fan fiction I
we're doing that because I think
actually that would work and I think
it's kind of the sort of thing they'll
do because it's the kind of thing that's
quite popular and modern yeah for
Studios to do
um
yeah they could have like multiple
stories going on
so the first first couple could be one
story then then the next next couple of
episodes of another story but they all
connect to the overarching story yeah I
think that way of us describing it was
like we'd have the SGC call that
everything else would hang off it's kind
of a way of kind of a good way of
describing it they'd have all these
little series but it's it's what Star
Wars what they're doing Star Wars
it's not um Marvel doing you know
they're having these movies and these
little series or only 10 episodes and
they might come back for a second season
they might not you know it's like and
and I think that's what they're going to
end up doing myself but
um when you've got such a large and well
built Out World why not you know and you
have something supportive fan base why
not hmm
foreign
what did we decide on um sg1 or
something else then by the way just show
you a hybrid of the two
yeah so my my idea was I there'd be uh
episode of the week how they used to do
it but
it would have an overarching
um there'll be an over there'll be an
overall Arc for the entire Series so you
could watch them individually just like
you can you could be started in the past
but it would contribute to the overall
story like sg1 really that's what sg1
and wasn't it had the overarched story
the gold and blah blah blah and SGC and
um I I hope they move away from this
sort of thing though they have to do
Atlantis they have to do that oh we lost
we can't get home thing or an SGU again
they did it again with SGU
um I hope they move away from that
because I
I'd like I think it limits the
creativity
I'd rather see something that allows
them to do whatever okay acley has just
talked about this animated SGC sg1 right
okay
I'd watch it
oh I'd watch it
I mean there already is a there is an
animated Stargate it's called Stargate
Infinity it's a Stargate please God
don't watch it yeah exactly it's not
very good to go watch it Infinity
it was bad it was pointed out making
four kids and that was just trying to
give MGM animation something to do it
was it was terrible but I I honestly
think if you think if you look at Star
Trek
the animated is the best bit Prodigy and
lower decks are way better than um
discovery
um I know Harris this is completely over
your head but I mean the last episode of
low decks was not just good low decks it
was an amazing Star Trek it was so good
um
neither of you care but
there is the opportunity to do that if
they do it properly
but it needs to be done as Canon
and for grown-ups or at least that we
can appreciate it it can't be a kid's
cartoon because nobody cares uh you know
you can do that that it's it's
seriously that it's got to be Clone Wars
style where yes it's it's directed
towards children but there are
decapitations most episodes
you know the main thing is it's balanced
Stargate Infinity wasn't Canon it was
nothing like the series it was it was
completely different
um it was um I can't even remember it
was so long ago but I remember all these
people with all colors over their faces
and things the only thing that was even
remotely the same was that there was a
Stargate wasn't it set in the future or
something
um well I think so yeah but the Stargate
didn't actually look like the Stargate
it looked more like Wormhole extreme
which is just ridiculous
you must have seen one Wormhole extreme
in what you've watched Harris no because
I think that's series eight
what means I'm just getting into it yeah
that's the uh the the the funny funny
crew essentially right
TV show that gives reliability yeah yeah
yeah yeah no that was the end of season
six or the beginning of season seven I
think uh there you go at least the first
time we see them or something like that
I'm not sure uh it was the alien guy
that was stuck on the planet uh the the
quirky little alien guy that said you
know what I kind of want to stick to
this and that I remember his name but he
was funny isn't great yeah
yeah I can't remember his name either
yeah
Shelley is lovely and I've just I think
she's just in this school I bought her a
sticker so guys you can buy Stargate
stickers outside that's shrek.com just
because it's Shelly wanted one for a
laptop there's a gap on her laptop about
that big so she's getting a perfect but
she doesn't have an opinion but we love
you still
um she runs the Facebook group and she's
took it from like having 200 people on
Facebook to over 1500 so thank you so
much we have a lovely Community there
well Stargate did have a mug bits
episode so I'm gonna have to point
Shelley across to it so a Dark Crystal
and a Stargate crossover
they didn't actually have a Muppets
episode though it wasn't but there were
no Muppets
it was there was a Thunderbirds kind of
episode oh they were puppets man they
were more like
[Music]
um
it was like Team America
yeah okay
all right the 200th episode uh Harris I
know you enjoy a recreational
um mind-altering experience occasionally
when you watch the 200th episode do it
sober
because I don't want to have those Tech
stuff you go what the [ __ ] is going on
I'm freaking out oh we well they
basically did the 200th episode was they
they let all the people that had been
involved writing everything to just do
like it was up it was like four bits was
it four different stories but they just
said do whatever you want and they did
they did basically parodied everything
and we're talking about honestly that
part of it was like Team America we're
not joking
right it's the best thing
because I don't want to ruin it but just
talk
it's so good it's so good you know it's
like oh it's just it was just actually
love letter too it was a love letter to
itself it was mental but it was yeah it
was just brilliant
um
as long as it doesn't take me out of it
like a old she-hulk's last episode did
that that I should not have smoked prior
to I was like what the hell is going on
right now this would probably be worse
you remembered another part of that
episode
he's like it's round I wanted to spin
make it spin damn it
I'm the general I say spin oh no
honestly they just they just let their
brains they're just like all all
shackles are off guys do whatever you
want and you know it's it's joyous it
was absolutely joyous
um
Team America
Kim jong-il's been dead for seven
decades not seven decades but a while
the rise of you mean
a little fat guy in his stilts
that's what I've got
um I can never go to North Korea I'll be
in trouble yeah the tribute to Farscape
was brilliant the Farscape one was with
uh the Asgard with the mustache wasn't
it yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
one more time come again say that
we'll do a video in a few weeks once
you've once Harris you've watched it
we'll do a video and we'll all just
break down the 200th episode into all
the little bits because it's just
glorious
and just do just just talk about it
because I think we could break
it's just very easy anyway if you guys
want to do want us to do that we'll
we'll do that
so I did have another question for you
um Amazon have not got the best
reputation now a lot of comments have
come in basically saying Amazon can't do
this they're going to destroy it and
I've tried to defend Amazon a little bit
I got called a shill I wish Amazon paid
me like some people think they do
because that'd be nice I could I would
I'd be happy if they just gave me my
subscription for free
um I've I'd say nice things about Amazon
if they gave me my subscription for free
[Music]
um
but uh maybe next time
um just just since Amazon that's how
cheap I am
um but I actually think Amazon did quite
a wide variety of stuff I don't think
they do a lot of work material and I
think they do TV shows for everybody
they do the boys and they do they
probably do do a lot of um you know
crappy stuff I don't watch for this made
for teen girls and things like this you
know and they do stuff that's work but I
think they do quite a wide variety of
stuff I'm I'm not orange and I think
they do some Really Brave stuff in in
their defense I'm not that worried about
Amazon doing this but what do you guys
think
no I'm glad you said said about the boys
because that's like the least woke thing
I can think of
and like
yeah
yeah the boy is is just it's one of them
things that pushes the What's the phrase
push the envelope I don't know how you
say it like it just it's one of those TV
shows that they
I don't even know how to explain it they
just do things that no other TV show
does and it's like it's shocking but
it's good
I don't know what that is but it's
pushing something but I can't I can't
envelope from the barrier pushing
whatever yeah
and decency occasionally
yes more than once watching the boys I
went all right I'm open-minded but what
the f
you can call it all of these things but
you can't call it work and that is
it's but it's technically the definition
of woke at the same time I'm just
Devil's advocating advocating here it is
the definition of woke by also just like
not it it degradates wokeness at the
same time as as being it does that make
sense yeah
um
yeah just answer the question uh if
Amazon scrub CSG would they sell the
franchise I don't think they would I
think um it's the 10th highest grossing
movie of mgm's History
it keeps trending on Twitter
which is just proof to Amazon over and
over again that people want to watch
this but I do think they will
basically
um Outsource making it
um MGM will find a production company
kind of like what they did with um well
that's what companies just do nowadays
they'll find a production company to
make it for them which means they would
have to sell
um or or a production company would have
to buy the license off MGM to produce a
TV show and Amazon and MGM would then
just hold the distribution rights I
think that's probably what's going to
happen
personally
um so I think even if even if we don't
get it if all the conversations are
happening now if they fizzle out and
they decide we're not going to push on
with Stargate they'll do it at some
point eventually
um
I think they've just got too many other
things on the boil at the moment trying
to deal with enemies
it was a much bigger job than they
thought it was going to be and
restructuring MGM has been a massive job
um everybody brings out the Wheel of
Time
every every to find every TV channel
ever has got [ __ ] TV shows they all do
there's always going to poop the scoop
at some point I don't think that's
necessarily the yeah what they did with
Wheel of Time was an absolutely fast
but
for every bad thing that Amazon or any
big stream of services done you can find
something else that they've done a great
job with so I don't think it's a
that brings up a question
I'm sorry but that's interesting but
that is interesting before
with with Amazon tackling it that does
bring up a good question people don't
seem to like even I I ended up liking
Lord of the Rings generally it was not
rings of power it I I don't think it was
woke or anything like that but I think
it was not the best television show it
could it was just boring it could have
been done better or and or is boring per
se for some people but it's a slow burn
and it's it's excellent television and
so is House of the Dragon where rings of
power was legitly just slow uh not bad
but slow and
A Wheel of Time people don't like and
that also has such rich source material
and things like that that my only
hesitation with Amazon themselves
because they took the expanse which also
has rich source material and those last
two seasons are not the first four
seasons and
I feel like they do well when they're
taking risks and having fun putting like
a good Omens out there putting Bosch out
there putting putting these different
kind of quirky uh flea bag things like
that where they have great ideas and
they they focus on the idea but I feel
like when Amazon's trying to focus on IP
that's they're they're thinking dollar
signs and they don't give a [ __ ] about
the story in a way in a way I don't
maybe not entirely but that's kind of
what it just feels like because they're
the things that they should be hitting
on all notes with that are hitting with
nearly none compared to the smaller
provocative things that they're hitting
all the notes on
you know and let's say we have to
remember they don't actually have a
studio they're not Sony or Warner
Brothers they don't own Studios what
they do is they Outsource and production
companies make stuff for them
all almost all of their movies and when
Amazon do a movie they'll do it in
partnership with MGM but it'll also have
to be in partnership with somebody else
because almost you look at any MGM movie
in the last 20 years they're almost all
in partnership with either Columbia
pictures or something like that somebody
that owns a studio
because they can't make anything
they don't have buildings we we figured
out they have one don't they didn't they
buy a building for Wheel of Time didn't
we figure that out whenever we were
figuring our billion dollar budgets out
I do vaguely remember that yeah that
Amazon did start to actually buy some
some Lots I think that would that is
going to be their long-term aim is to
become a prop production company but you
gotta remember Amazon's still a baby
the reason why they wanted to buy MGM
was because they wanted to be taken
seriously
that's the point they wanted the IP and
they want the MGM name you know
um
it's like a Chinese car company buying
mg over here
they're buying the badge they're buying
the history that goes with it you know
it's um
that that's that was the point
um but that but they need Studios they
need
they need land they need a place to film
yeah and that's that's what they need to
do if they want to do it long term I
hope that's what they'll do long term
um and I would have thought it was
cheaper in the long run isn't it
you can use it
yeah because they don't at all they need
to have a big deal
um
with
um somebody that owns something like
Pinewood Studios has just had a big deal
signed with Disney Disney have done a
long-term deal with them too for for
their for Studio space because they I
mean they've got their own studios in in
California but they needed more so they
don't want to build it so they've signed
a big deal with it they need to do that
there are other companies that that
Amazon could do that with
um
they just need to do it they could do
they could do a pinewood to be honest
and they probably haven't just got
studios in England they've got Studios
all over the world
so Brazil weird
um
I've just read his name
yeah the profile is licensed again it's
like again it's made by somebody else
um for Amazon and then Amazon just know
the distribution rights the expanse was
made by I think it's called amkron
I forget the name of the production
company
that sounds right might be right
somebody will tell me this dude anyway
um that's why it was like they um amkron
made the show we're gonna I'm gonna
stick with it now I'm just gonna go with
it even if somebody corrects me in the
comments I'm just gonna stick around so
I'm crying make the expanse they said
they sold it to
um sci-fi in America was it and then it
was Netflix the rest of the world for
two three series
um Netflix decided not to take it so
they sold so they went to Amazon but all
Amazon did there was they bought the
distribution rights for the next three
series
um so I'll come I was so close
I put an r in there
damn it Bob
pretend it's our prom
so close
um but you know that's and that's that's
hopefully what they'll do with Stargate
anyway
um but I I don't have anything I wasn't
doing it I think that's the you know
people are uh jumping on the bandwagon
it's it's made by it's going to be done
by Amazon so it's going to be [ __ ]
yeah
you've got to remember Amazon aren't
making the show they're funding the show
and they're Distributing the show it'd
be other companies who are making the
television show
so what you're going to really be doing
is when you know who's making it look at
their previous bodies of work and then
make a judgment
or just watch it and then make a
judgment
because it's not it's not Amazon's fault
it kind of is but it's Amazon
it's not Amazon making it is what I'm
trying to say yeah there's there's still
going to be managers and in charge and
they still decide who runs it and
they're still going to be watching over
it and going now we like this we don't
like that and they were doing that with
MGM before
um the sale went through with Stargate
they were interfering
um yeah I I was told they're actually
going to be funding it and then
Distributing it that's going to be their
primary roles oh yeah they get away
they're going to have they're going to
sit there or in when they want to but
it's gonna be made by someone else could
they do something like this with um you
know because obviously we had the eight
Chevron address for SGU which Harris
doesn't know about that's what we do now
if everyone was Atlantis right
no that's when they oh did they do the
front lines as well hey Chevron it took
them to eight Chevrons to get to
Atlantis at least okay the one they did
the same for us to you anyway it was
eight Chevron so it could never get the
eight Chevron to engage
um but um I forgot about that so um
could there be more than eight Chevrons
would there be a point to more than
eight chevrons
the second day I saw eight Chevrons in
Atlantis I was like all right so closer
galaxies or maybe galaxies on the other
side of of where we're front facing I
guess to start now really
you're a Ford it could be a distance
thing I'm sure everyone's connects you
to Destiny eight Chevrons connects you
to another galaxy Destiny has gone
through thousands of galaxies so
there will be
addresses that maybe they'd have to
figure out to get to those galaxies that
could be a story of how they they
finally get to Destiny Okay well here's
the throw spanner and that works in we
know the Stargate can be used as a time
machine we know it can travel through
time
so
10 11 12 chevrons
to actually
purposefully do it instead of it just
being a solar flare
I like that yeah there's only nine
Chevrons on the game
oh shut up
you can't just add chevrons
well there's always more Chevrons than
nine there's nine
there's nine different symbols on a
Stargate no no no nine Chevrons but
there's 28 symbols oh actually you mean
the actual things that lock in the place
well it could just go around again like
we were dialing like
sort of thing
but yes no you're right oh okay in that
case we'd have to build a new gate
wouldn't we but after we'd have to maybe
we'd find a gate with 10 chevrons
we find a gate with 11 chevrons
we checked behind the surface in
Atlantis and find one
that's in the uh that's a nice idea they
could explore the aura gate Network
assuming there is one yeah bring any
evil furlings this this idea got
generally panned when I first studied
that everyone's like no no they're
pacifists I feel like I'm willing people
over with it a little bit
um that we can hear you Matt we can
literally just like evil angry Ewoks
yeah exactly evil Ewoks
excellent good well we have just pushed
an hour and I have
one last question
just to ask you guys that I wondered if
and again in this in the audience as
well tell me in the comments
how important is it do you think that we
need to find a lead actor you know
because the other room a little while
ago that was Liam Hemsworth was being
tapped up to be the front man like
Richard Dean Anderson was
um for sg1
do you think it's important to bring in
a name that you kind of know
for the new series
or doesn't it matter and I've got a
kind of because obviously we have actors
for SG Atlantis I didn't know any of
them
that's what I'm going to base my answer
on
uh SGU they did they brought in a couple
of known actors so Robert Carlisle and
so what do you guys think is it is it
important do we need to find that that
guy that person depends on the type of
show they make because if they go like
another sg1 type of Route it would help
to have someone at least
big TV like RDA was at the time to come
in there and you know get that initial
viewership going but if they do a show
like an SGC
the only person that I could see them
like needing to cast big name per se
would be
making whoever's running the Stargate
command itself actually be you'd be a
secondary character generally because
he's sending teams off to go do things
or she's sending teams up to go do
things
but I feel like that would be the only
character you would really need to have
gravitas with at first
hmm if that wasn't that
my My worry is if they do that I I
always think in any in any show really
but in sci-fi I think in particular some
ways if you get the casting right
it can go a long way look look to bring
up Stargate against Star Trek sorry
strange new worlds they've got the
casting bang on people like the
characters I would actually argue that
that show is no better written and no
more interesting than discovery
the difference is the characters and
Discovery are [ __ ] nobody cares if they
all died I'd just be like yay we're
gonna get some new characters
um Captain uh sorry the Birmingham Woman
Brian whatever her name is
I have absolutely no interest in it at
all and I know you guys have not watched
this but just trust me they're rubbish
strangely worlds they're interesting
all of a sudden people love strange new
worlds hate discovery
you think that the casting right I'll
tell you about a good example for this
as well is sorry actually maybe the
casting that like Warner Brothers have
done with the DC Universe that they've
got the casting bang on and even when
the films aren't particularly good
people still go and watch them
Aquaman is not a good film I don't care
what anybody says it's not a good film
but
you'll watch it because Jason Momoa is
bang on in it he's brilliant
so
let's just bring back Jason my mind for
Stargate
oh man if we could pay justice
but oh man that would be so good
just what do you think I I mean as I'm
going through they have so many options
they could choose from like yeah Robert
Patrick I just saw Robert frickin
Patrick yesterday I had a tweet about it
because I was just like wait wait wait
wait wait
all the time
no way no I haven't seen him in real
life but can you go I'm gonna say can
you go and ask him if he Stargate first
person I would I'm on board of that but
in season seven of sg1 there is Michael
Rooker you know yondu and and regarding
the Galaxy movies he's in Tombstone he's
in The Walking Dead been in everything
he's a colonel on the same level as
O'Neill and you know he just has the say
of the day in that episode
they have so many great people to choose
from they literally have
so many famous people that are already
like baked in that are much more popular
today than they were back then that
would be easy just to bring back and
there already is a place in the world
for them so
how much does how much do you want to
watch that show Ronan and teal could
just go kicking butt through the Galaxy
just I'm just literally stepping through
the gate for a new world each week like
The A Team like we're just here to help
you know just like if you're in trouble
even nowhere else to help
you can hide I want to see I want to see
tilt pi
foreign
that's actually my ringtone my text tone
on my phone that line is just indeed oh
man I'm gonna have to change that I need
that
um
is there Ackerman after Amber Heard
they've cut you out haven't they aren't
they haven't they put in yeah they were
already working on cutting her out just
from this first one
at least he's gonna do it I've forgotten
a real name but apparently Khaleesi's
gonna do it a mirror Emilio Clark who
might be the replacement yeah I don't
know if it's gonna be an Aquaman too
because of contractual things but
who knows we'll have to sing but um she
needs every Amber Heard needs everybody
she can get her Amazon
anyways let's just come with 17-ish
Seasons adventure to run multiple season
so without a reboot
um is there enough angle to cover a
continuation unless this does SGA SG
ascended I I think there's enough for
them to do a continuation
it's just difficult I mean we've talked
about this before doing a continuation
of a show after 12 years is really hard
um
for it to work you know it's like
I would say but anyway guys we're over
an hour we promised we would only do an
hour we've got to have something to talk
about again when we come back in a
couple of weeks and do this again so
guys
it's been it's been an honor as always
um thank you Matty for
um
shutting up on your told you
um Harris it's been a pleasure no one's
actually said shut up Matt today so you
know I've told you
nobody in the comments has told you
should have people once so
guys thank you the comments through the
comments
but thank you so much for coming
everybody in the comments today you've
been absolutely brilliant some really
really good comments um some some really
good and thoughtful thoughtful um
insights and everything as always we
really do have the best subscribers so
guys
say bye
bye-bye see ya
thank you
oh